throw back welcome back to the dazzling
pasta thousand ten Tommy good tag hey
I'm like weirdly scared why scared okay
we this week we're doing something a
little big deal
it was sort of requested it was sort of
lizra class it was requested straight-up
requested by you guys and also incited
by you guys before we get there though
yes if you get that such as knockouts
off you buy me IDs the wonderful
underwear that you can get delivered to
hell you designed every month
micro modal fabric three times softer
than cotton a dope company right now you
get your first pair for 20% off and free
shipping my going to me Andy's calm
slash Jenna Julian is one of my favorite
design this looks like the rose and
beading beasts in the beginning route 16
glass yeah it does right you could be
wearing that on your butt and you you
guys got a try it's really soft also
brought to you by wink wink is a wine
delivery service where you get wine
deliver to your don't your front door
without having to go anywhere and they
select wines custom based on your
palates you take a palette profile quiz
and they get your sense of flavor and
what you like and then all the sudden
wines that your friend or you have to do
no work so go to try wink that's t ry
winc calm slash annejulien for 20 bucks
off your first order and complimentary
shipping shipping thank you guys thank
you in three communities oh okay what
are you doing today well someone on
Twitter started retweeting who has it
looks like I don't remember their
accounting 20 you dicks I think Laura
might have been the first one somebody
started retweeting Julian's like old
tweet not only retweeting like replying
I replied to a couple they were pretty
funny but so to be fair we're looking
what are the years that we're looking at
2009 yeah she was 90 doesn't either
right or I don't know that's that's
that's the date that I have plugged in
I'm looking 2009-10 yeah like basically
to avenge has done right so but I will
23 how old are you in 2010 or 2009 17
yeah so like Julian's are really funny
oh my god - I mean mine are super
embarrassing but you were like a
teenager I was tweeting nonsense yes and
people are come replying commenting and
like retweeting all my old tweets trying
to make sense of a lot of that which
it's hard because some of them they
really don't make any sense if you don't
if you're not me like you know I know
what I was trying to say at the time but
so I get that I feel super fortunate
that I did not have Twitter when I was
17 yeah I kind of I kind of wish I did I
mean like I look I'm so glad I was on
YouTube I couldn't imagine with the [ __ ]
I [ __ ] in what I made anyway so
Jenna's going to read mild tweets and
I'm gonna read hers and we're going to
kind of just like ask the clarification
does that make sense
weeks on trial yeah we're a we go we be
what oh my god all right so you starting
at the bottom of the top I don't know
I'm just gonna start you can start all
right why don't you go why don't you go
first
well I mean I can't even do some of
yours justice because the spell yeah
it's all Robin jealous how hmm okay this
is July 22nd 2010 I know KN know it
sounds like I'm exaggerating God but
today I'm the most sore I've IV ever
been dot dot every muscle is sort
individually dot signs of hashtag puttin
in work I hate myself I already hate
this I was I was on Twitter in high
school tweeting a t-shirt I found I was
on Twitter you did like explain everyone
no I'm just saying something I was into
had school tweeting the [ __ ] that like a
youtubers tweet now like all the hard
work that they're doing and like look
how look I'm grinding I am all that all
it is is a Phillies blunt with beauty oh
my god okay so can I explain I went
ahead was that if there's actually
really no story but my buddy Brandon and
my buddy answer we would like Pete
three musketeers we hang out all the
time and I can't remember what we were
doing but we were in like a convenience
store getting like some [ __ ] sodas or
some [ __ ] being idiots and behind the
cat we were in eighteen I don't think
all behind the counter there was
something called Philly's blunt and we
for some reason thought it was so funny
so we just started dying laughing when
we're at the Conner and then we kept
saying all night all it is is a Philly's
blunt it and even if you were there it
like really wasn't that funny but that's
two other people besides me knew what
that meant until I know but you can read
any mind I don't want to just embarrass
you mess up okay check out my new video
how to trick people into thinking you're
good looking
wait let me seriously let me see that
link oh my god
July July night literally seven years
ago to the day
wait Wow oh that's crazy week that video
come on today
seven years ago maybe no way oh there's
tweezing seven years ago I don't know a
lot of the links don't even work anymore
yeah no they don't yeah that's wild
I'm gonna go some before the video
making he got one yeah I got when you
thinking bout breakfast I'm heating up
my dinner dot dot now I'm a menace God
as my witness
okay so just disclaimer here maybe like
forty six percent of my tweets and I for
J Cole quote yeah that's going to say is
that a J called a comical quote okay
getting my exercise TV on smiley face
emoji let me do that what is it my
exercise teeth I think that was so it
like while I lived in Boston we had
Comcast so they had this like on-demand
was like their babe service or whatever
and you could go on there and just pick
from workout programs and I would work
out in my living room
mmm-hmm yeah just get max like you are
serving sort of for like stupid stuff
they don't give away p90x for free they
give you a stupid
that's for free monday is my business
day it's just this time it's Monday is
my business day job out yeah I would
like log on to literally every website
that there is and try and like freelance
and book goes with dancing games all
kinds of [ __ ] just rope and then the
rest of the week I just went out there
and worked for almost no money all the
time alright if you're content with
anything maybe it's time to get out of
the game so passive-aggressive this
injustice ha ha ha and then a Vimeo link
[Laughter]
that's so funny
great workout no nap time because Julian
Cruz in with 3 eggs around with just a W
the homies dot dot on that supper fun
level tweet photo link ok click on it
supper fun the [ __ ] yeah man I need to I
need to the numbers see inception again
who wants to see it W need W me keep my
new shots on this book Facebook but you
wrote s book and then smiley face and
then link doesn't work and then it says
oh no that's personally I don't like
model shop yeah thanks oice should we
appease them yeah paint them Julie
getting ready for work ii genkai
let's fine with that it's cute all yours
are harmless and cute mine are stupid
listen LC yeah inception with CP in the
homies we get it you saw inception if
Chilean vp's yeah good CP CP
turning with CP med CD I know what CB is
now let's see key might have been the
precursor to CB map shall a inception
always have two dots in between those
only a full ellipses design even three
dots
it's a 2.5 soldiers nap chalet inception
out W the homies that sounds like a
solid lineup to me alright let me
explain when she started to eat about
inception something really got to me
goes shall a means go to Sports Chalet
no like this sporting goods store yeah I
love going to sports and so you took a
nap you went to Sports Chalet and then
you saw inception with the homies yes
and now I'm going to make your silver
pants blue oh that's number four year
old virgin there we go he's painting
little action figures yeah nice nice
nice all I know
with no W is I got a double casket
[ __ ]
with four days five days let me explain
my days let me go back one tweet and
then explain that so CB it's the for
casket buddies that sounds really more
of an in [ __ ] up but me and my buddy
Andrew call each other Casper casket
buddies because we were like homies
realized we would die together and be
casket buddies and so that was a double
casket treat mm-hmm
you're judging me so hard we're going to
judge you I'm not use for things tweet
before that is bros before hos always a
difference forever just re be ve are
spelling like wasn't my heart so you're
on Twitter July 16th Chalet with it w ID
I T
you were just fortunately again yeah I
love for Saleh what are you getting
under armor and spells like Cologne like
we're dog says when I'll see ya I blend
I met smart tan again imagine that yeah
I worked all the time
yeah I wish the links worked because
that would make these a lot better I
know that they don't breakfast that snug
with menthe got body is done two hard
days behind me dot dot resin Tom dot dot
then two more ahead wrestling tomorrow
yeah are spoken code basically let his
breakfast at snug with Mont Andrew
Monson re with my good buddy
I called him Monty and I saw him much
Snug Harbor in Santa Monica was a
breakfast spot doesn't notice anymore so
that have you been there thing he was
right next to Whole Foods on Wilshire
can't deal W this radio nonsense anymore
dot dot got to get back to that iPod in
the web anywhere so oh gotta get back to
that iPod in the width I feel like we
should just read mine yours are near
anywhere near as embarrassing as new
public yet no because I was 23 2010 yeah
it's like doesn't like not quite the
same level of what the [ __ ] subscribe
gig for Saturday sick like you're just
working that's your life but I'm just
like tweeting nonsense headed to AT&T
store now I think y'all know why
hashtag iPhone 4 I like to you like that
we were watching so like to release all
blogs last night and like it I told you
it's [ __ ] amazing and cool when you
go back and watch our own blog that you
when you started and like you know a
month goes by is cool to watch like you
know a month old vlogs just to see what
you were doing remember and we were
watching a video where Julian literally
used Apple pay for the first time and
was so excited or like mind blown by
like we're living in the future y'all
like those vlogs are only and every vlog
you make after that it's only to be like
more and more fun to watch as time goes
by like imagine 10 years from now on I'm
talking on Apple pay like it's been bet
negative thing and boom over pain [ __ ]
with a fake little let's just switch
over to meeting might retest okay go
ahead
you responded to a tweet that Forrest
Griffin tweeted me this wrote a lot all
right what else you got headed to at
Gold's Gym Dada NO explode this time oh
my god that pre-workout game two is
three Slurpees round two or the link
that doesn't work and round three
boy that is a lot of Slurpees you like
Slurpee I guess Oh Parks and Rec okay so
this this is this is literally my best
Halloween costume ever and it was me
dressed as Chris Traeger from Parks and
Rec yeah and cement and I got retweeted
by Parks and Rec and that was like the
coolest thing in the world
Wow haha humor night already
what does [ __ ] Julian it's a humor night
already I like when you say humor
objectives soft with the main homies dot
dot dot objective complete what the [ __ ]
does that mean getting drunk I think
getting soft with panda with the bro why
can't why don't you like refer to
anything is what it is I just always
spoke in code I was trying to be close
alright Julian that itself at social
network dot go bomb what does that mean
you miss my mom got a job painting for
set design in the movie social network
Oh doesn't make any sense
back in SM it feels bomb beeps air
Monica oh yeah why don't you just ate
Santa Monica man these late night meals
at Wolfgang are two cuts we love games
King Park
that's a restless King person these late
night meals at Wolfgang are to pledge I
must speak like a Cirque du Soleil is so
legit show tonight was by far the best
they need to have shows in LA it'll
change love
this one's good too in saucer to say one
time and it's don't change much Liam
Neeson is a boss unknown is an awesome
movie James Bond asked oh my god doing
what he said he's going there because
his mom thought it would make him happy
uh yeah BC Bosh and Wade are holding his
hand exclamation point
those a basketball tweet evil with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about it I'm gonna I'm gonna
delete my account with Noemi and sei Z
seize the moment trying to freeze it and
own it squeeze it and hold it because we
consider these moments these minutes
golden at M&M I tag him Cassie she's
right
I'm like I'm actually like horrified I'm
cringing like I'm physically from
getting shivery Cirque tonight is the KA
at the MGM Grand super pumped we get it
you need to start to sell a any saw
inception do you see an inception
Jillian what you do is you can did you
see inception um no I haven't seen it
nothing to do but get my bras on with
two N's
on Ron's on okay this one's good what
got into Chapman that's so sick si si si
and they want me to play for um just
adding on to another thought to my busy
head right now hectic oh my god what is
wrong with my little tiny highschool
brain Nike outlet
Oh F all ellipses this time dot dot just
know T starting to get fitted dot
hashtag thug life thug life Nike outlet
plug life and that wasn't even like said
Nolan that was that wasn't even like um
self-aware thug life I was like I
thought I was living recycle I said to
make yet
yeah what else you got I ain't give it
all they got
so they flop so hey watch oh god it's
another jingle you like you liked
inception you like Jake oh yeah yeah I
see oh another one
I feel like inception is a must like
this is out who's down whoa
Julian have you seen reception do you
want to do something it's a good movie
you should see it I think you might like
it
Julian Julian Julian Julian Julian all
right I get it I get it I get it I tweet
about obsession ha ha
cops walking through the house and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god okay let me explain that so I
had an 18th birthday party at my house
this is actually the night like I really
met mark for the first time but I had an
eighteenth birthday party with way too
many people like I invited like probably
15 20 friends and they all brought
friends which got out of hand
yeah and his own my mom's house how's
the seen you in high school I was living
the [ __ ] dream and these cops came
because there were some noise complaints
so they started walking through the
house meanwhile like there was beer like
everywhere and like actually one of my
friend's dad's was carrying beer back to
us a lot of cops whatever they were cool
and like that you know they didn't
really get us in trouble but that's what
that sweet was what does honestly f e--
FFF turtle mean I need to see her
honestly
f a turtle uh like soccer turtle
well yeah but why in what context
because I something something was done
to me I didn't like what a turtle did to
me or something living on the edge just
being in this turtle out car pray for my
safety
turtle out car that's what it says
Turtles out car I don't think you're
reading there right
read it right there what is the turtle
doubt car turtled our car
I have no clue what I could have meant
oh man all right I'm gonna try outside
of the fund what you trying to find
specific this one this one this one had
a lot of you guys confused I saw this
one night okay another nice little shot
in the sm mirror sm mirror is one word
so it looks likes mirror so you guys
were like did you have a stroke like
what was this tweak the SN mirror was
our local newspaper the santa monica
mirror and I was terrible at sentences
in English so I wrote another nice
instead of a nice nice another nice
little shot like I meant to say another
basically my picture was in the
newspaper that's what that was for
baseball Oh cute going to swoop the
cousin from the train station got so
recovered physically from this morning
solo or dot dot only because I hash tag
put in work but it looks like Putin work
didn't work
Oh doing isin guide to current even rise
in crime to any other kid now I can't
touch us can't touch us where you at
Varane where you at that's a dub let's
go oh yeah senior year to junior year of
high school we had this horrible coach
his name was I think robbed Iran like
the worst coach in the world everyone
hated it and he he basically blew like a
winning season we had Tyler Skaggs who
was drafted right at high school
pitching for us like we had the dream
team are doing here and we he [ __ ]
everything up so we lost and it like it
ended on a really sour note so everyone
hated that coach and then he left and
started coaching for another school that
we like to part one of our competition
schools down the road and so our senior
year we played them and we played
against our old coach and then we beat
them so that was me tweeting like in
your face
yeah but what's uh ah almost out of here
stack that cheese probably be working
some like dumb minimum-wage jobs
snapping $8 an hour's worth of cheese
looks like that cheese site that cheese
to my guard line but and weird much love
for little punchy like I'm tweeting
about Lil Wayne yeah gonna miss you in
your spirit for a while well that's
happening we went to jail yeah yeah game
at Cleveland tomorrow you're going to be
on my mind for this one Weezy oh my god
Julian uncle Oh
dumbass umpires on [ __ ] Mars just got
thrown out humor don't even know what
they do in was to n I was I got kicked
out of the game I really like your use
of the word humor that's so humid
that's what my friends still say that
humor like I was so Kelton humor I
thought she was humor it's just I can
you see later in our cast is not humor
it's correct I can't remember what I did
get booted from the game you got booted
yeah I got it ejected that's what that
tweet was oh yeah Empire definitely met
LeBron James in my dream last night
hell yeah do it it's funny how dreams
can tell you so much about what's going
through your head and what's important
in your life I want you to get excited
man annum innum moon you never see it
coming
you just get it get to see it go when I
play is that right no clue no no clue no
clue never see em it's probably weird
never see it come and just get to see ya
f7 work
what else you got up I responded to one
that just said LLL girls are dumb to see
um then high school girls were dumb and
then I respond to another one that was
like my future plans include and it's :
we need this game tomorrow and I was
like is that all that is all your plan
why if you don't okay um I really like
girls are dumb well who didn't tweet
some [ __ ] like that in high school
flash college when we why did like what
my Twitter just switched to Jenna
Jillian podcast and [ __ ] lost
everything I was searching I don't know
alright done with that sketch sketch
asked shall a but def is successful more
than midnight why are you always
unfortunate the [ __ ] is it well I need
to get back to my spot one phone cut
damage I um why why you I don't [ __ ] any
telling about our deftly I had I was
living the thug life I had tried
honestly they say middle child sucks and
I'm really starting to see the dynamic
and why it does because it does all
pretty insightful tweet yeah like a
human Carmen
being the middle child is weird what's
that hunter that um chiropractor top top
getting ready what our flight getting
ready to play the next day probably
everything ready to play Castleman we
can lack a chiropractor and then like
that's me getting ready I was getting
ready with the chiropractor oh this is
that girl that you had a crush on you
tweeted her so much ah Julian you're a
nameless Sheila
good morning hopefully it's nice out to
[ __ ] out that's a huge suite okay I just
read this one that media just got down
with Palmdale talk to those fools up we
got in a full bra with Palmdale High
School like a bench-clearing brawl [ __ ]
the school's up
who you calling fools bleh mmm that's
how I tossed a one full babe maybe you
can't get down with 18 year old me like
retro actively we can't look in your
drain is my aesthetic yeah
[ __ ] to those fools up [ __ ] with a few
CCD [ __ ] to those holes up but like why
are we getting in brawls and not in a
high school game going on I don't know
I'm a crazy moon [ __ ] or just bored I
just know the mo as you see AAA I
tweeted it HSN go so much that's very
see Julian I was just a fan of his why
couldn't I be a fan why you ought to
judge me
you literally tweeted this girl that you
liked like every single day okay so I
think this might be the first tweet ever
hit indeed so sore from those stairs
time to recharge and then a link yes
that was my first tweet oh my god kermin
trying other hey Brent
it's Julian sulamita hope everything's
well I'm headed up to quiz' Oslo for a
workout with the coach right now okay do
you want to explain me explain that yes
Brent Mayne was a professional catcher
for the Royals
I think the Dodgers and my dad as like I
think one of my birthday gifts when I
was in high school bought me private
lessons
catching lessons with him and it was one
of the [ __ ] coolest things ever
because like Catchings my favorite thing
ever like defense I look like defense I
didn't often so I loved catching and
sort of the train with one of like a
really prominent
anyway he was from San Luis Obispo it's
Julian's Oleta
little you also have at Drake it's a
cold world so homey bundle up she needed
to know I was just trying to help him
that's a Jay Collier okay I should have
said it's a cold world huh me
bundle up with me unease cuz right now
you got 11 andis I'm like I'm ready to
leave just like I'm ready to walk Johnny
probably wanted me to say that to him
back then I'm ready to leave you know if
I included them the tweet he would have
bought me I need his back then and then
you know what I mean no communities was
around back then but you still for the
bottom of back then right now guys you
can get your mayonnaises softest most
comfortable underwear you'll ever wear
the dopest designs in the absolute like
I hate coolest colors like every think
about this guy's your underwear is going
to look fresh every month you can get
new designs every month delivered right
to your door or you can just buy one
time under undies like right right from
your freaking computer which is amazing
okay
they have guest designers each month so
the designs are not just the same they
have new aesthetics all the time which
is a very cool and I literally wear
nothing else I'm wearing them right now
can you see I'm done listening to you
I'm wearing Mandy's right now right now
that you can get 20% of your first pair
and free shipping when you go to meet
undies icon flash annejulien micro model
fabric guys three times soft in the
cotton think about that think about how
cotton have soft cotton is and then
think three times more softly thuggin
stop you don't need to go buy boring
underwear anymore at the store you just
go to me and East Arkansas Senator
Julian and you get your bright beautiful
wonderful underwear and put it on your
butt it's going to feel amazing and you
won't regret it
Thank You munities also week guys if you
have a hard time picking out which wine
to drink and you don't know how to get
the flavors that you like and you get
confused by you know choosing what
bottles look cool or you know whatever
wink takes all the guesswork out of it
okay wink helps you out right there you
go to try wink on that steer why winc
and you take a quick pallet profile quiz
which is basically they ask you a couple
questions about your flavor taste of
what you like what you don't like
certain thing
that you enjoy in certain food and once
you take that really quick quiz they now
say that to your profile and use it to
select certain wines that would fit your
palate it's a very cool process and then
before you know it all the wine is
literally on your front door your
doorstep and you just drink it it's that
simple
you don't have to go to the store and
they're going to count the shipping for
you guys and they give you 20 bucks off
your first order when you get a try wink
that's t ry winc comm / Jenna Julian you
can join for free skip any month and
cancel anytime plus the link will have a
100% satisfaction guarantee so you never
pay for a bottle but you don't like
check it out
Thank You Fontes thank you hashtag ads
you got for me bid I'm trying to change
the date look up older tweet Schoology
to point listen oh that's my oldest
wheat what is from what year 2010 is my
almost week ah okay but Twitter like
Twitter wasn't big at all yeah I joined
because a couple of my friends were on
it yeah and like that was a way that we
could like tweet like like cool people
like cool spelling of [ __ ] and like not
have our parents see it basically damn
face recognition thumbprint security I
feel like a secret agent I'm gonna be up
all night learning this comp so I got a
new laptop for college and a head of
some Princeton or something was a
garbage computer when it was this little
PC laptop broke down on me so fast
shinza had that red baja oh man
I don't know I like sorry last Lisa
so just wish things could be easy
sometimes just for a quick sec I don't
want to have to worry about all the BS
whatever keep grindin game today oh my
god I want to slap my old self
keep going into him dream keep crying
nothing feels as bomb as I do right now
working out is my outlet [ __ ] all the DF
stay grounded what is wrong with you
who taught you to say grinded I like I
like foresaw the future I was like I
want to see like 2017 vloggers sorry
picked up the tux and ready for some pre
prom in tonight tweeted pre promise did
you okay when you were in high school
did you guys have like promposals
because that wasn't the thing no well I
mean I didn't none of my friends and
maybe people better I wasn't it was even
a thing no I voted to this photo check
it out no there's no link doing work
yeah all the links are [ __ ] you where
I couldn't find anything on my Twitter
they're all dis little work yeah I mean
I can search more I just feel like yours
is like so much more mature and less
embarrassing here's the piece like only
clapping at your Twitter okay and it's
with Grandpa something he still beats me
something I love to do that little kid
he still beats Mia what the hell did
what the [ __ ] hell
why went around Lesnar hung on by the
hair of his chinny chin chin Brock
Lesnar poppin on New York New York
rollercoaster is that in Vegas or it
doesn't it I've never been on their
album like twice is it fun just a
rollercoaster I don't know mmm do you
like roller coasters yeah it's fun it's
pretty extreme you go upside down once I
think wow let me go inside a little not
extreme
Wow free slurpie Toronto yeah already
read those oh my god yeah I'm like out
of them now yeah should I like change
the dates that's I just tried to do and
he said the 2010 was your oldest tweet
you know what if I change it to like
2011 and then I don't you tell me that
secret account that you had before this
one so I can look at those tweets
because I had one too I'll try to find
it I'm looking at right now I'm not
getting I'm not putting it out on the
inner I know but you can about it all
there's no tweets on it oh wait oh look
there might be a different one one thing
I like
I kept promo a Mike Mike Inc like this
is my kick message me what was I oh oh
my God look at my oh my god what I only
had three tweets and it's a ha ha too
bad
stop following this Twitter yeah so my
old Twitter um when I search it nothing
comes up because I think I basically
changed my at so then all those like
those would just be undermine mm-hmm
okay yeah I don't know is that it I mean
I don't know pretty much I mean there
those are your tweets it's well I
apologize for my old please why that
you're like really sweet and innocent
like it's maybe I was just grinding okay
oh my god you're gonna handle my hustle
but if I met you and you're using the
word grinding like we never wanna
started dating there's not a chance
Rison nah no today no hashtag rise
hashtag and hashtag grind know you can't
handle how hard I grind yes I can I know
you you do not grind my grind you just
live your life I grind know I work hard
know I work really the definition of
grind is to like take a little thing and
then smash it together with something
else
I do a life not what you do to light
your life I can't handle my grind now I
smash it yes it can life is in big
pieces and then I grind you up into
little pieces
no life in the universe are far superior
and larger than any single person and no
one gives a [ __ ] about your grinding
they can't handle my grind
yes everyone can handle your writing
they can't have a cook that's true no
one can handle your j.cole close game
going to be thinking about you for this
game Weezy I oh my god I thought you
know what's crazy you know what really
brings me back to the the mindset of
like when you think everything is the
end of the world like everything's
dramatic everything is so important you
are on this quest and everything you do
is like paving your life and it's all
it's so insignificant when you believe
at the time everything always feels like
that's it that's all there is
and so those tweets are so indicative of
that mindset of like you are you're so
dramatic
about the tiniest things and you want to
make a big deal about them on a platform
where I knew my mom wouldn't see it
mm-hmm like literally like tweeted like
my mom I really complained about lunch
water sometimes yeah but it's just you
know it's funny like it's funny how just
like literal tweets will bring you back
into that whole mindset I feel like the
closest thing that I have to anything
like that is like I we had AI AM or AOL
Instant Messenger yeah you know what
that is yeah you say em and so I had
like some conversations with people like
I was dating quote quote dating some
kids in middle school like from another
school that I like literally never met
was at a mutual friends we like only
would chat on a I'm only really you're
like all mode was yeah but I never met
him and then I like broke up with him
over a I am or whatever and I like saved
one of those conversations like I like
have actually printed out and saved them
in my like shoebox and layers but that's
the closest that I have but you like
reading those I've read them a very long
time but they are just like everything's
super dramatic yeah like my away
messages were always very like sappy and
sad and stupid
yeah me too me too you know it like just
went back to all the [ __ ] I was quoting
like it was all such dramatic like you
know overcome this and that you know
you're in [ __ ] high school in Santa
Monica there's nothing we don't like
you're fine just shut up no Sonny on
your baby days the year no bad weather
like your oh man it's so funny though
because it doesn't it doesn't you know
like you think about it and and when I
go back to Santa Monica now everything
is so different or maybe with the same
even high school they've changed the
line but it's just it's such a prominent
memory for me those years it's wild this
wild but I'm it's wild but that's the
same account that I have now wait no
like yeah I mean I'm really like I have
Twitter until I like made it my youtube
name when I was trying to like make them
all sort of magic other than I mean
hashtag brand but like not even like
that I just sort of did the best that I
could you know but um I'm like glad that
to where didn't exist when I was like 17
because that was sucked yeah I mean
you're good sport
yeah I appreciate it I mean I also think
that like as cringy at some of those
tweets where I like you said like I am
kind of proud that I wasn't like a
little [ __ ] okay you're pretty
harmless yeah there's not a lot of
Violation on there that that indicates
that I was you know in bad [ __ ] or even
just like talk to people poorly or like
you know like a lot you know like a lot
of these 18 17 year old kids who are
saying something in and out the way they
talk to girls the way to talk to people
is just like this there's a lot of
teenagers but if you were to go back and
look at them it's like with a look at
their Twitter without context the way
that we just sit and read some of those
tweets like imagine what they're going
to look like in many years like run me
over with your tractor and [ __ ] you
my ass at Billy Ray Cyrus later that
shit's [ __ ] wild yeah
you mean for sure person you're pretty
harmless yeah you tweeted about Lil
Wayne and that you'd be thinking about
him I would really unfortunate about it
and I really
remember exactly what game that was
you're a kid you know what this whole
podcast is dedicated to easy yeah I mean
I think it's it's likely to run into
yeah well thank you guys pretty great
guy
thank you guys for letting us read over
old tweets mostly mine also thank you
for taking all of them up and retweeting
them and hell yeah girls there's down
spread the cringe guys just spread it
all around for all of us to enjoy until
you can find more old crazy [ __ ] to
spread around and until next week
just just grind grind check it can find
the grind don't stop I'll [ __ ] it's
Monday to rise & grind you have to you
have to go get it
stop that chalet on your way and go and
go get it
wait although is unfortunately even
still there I thought a clothes own oh
maybe it is the one in Santa Monica oh
did it close down I thought so okay well
don't go to shall egg but maybe go to
Big Five but don't don't
it's no no that's awful advice brinded
ever walk by your competition is
sleeping you be grinding it's like it's
not even sound advice like go get some
sleep you're not gonna be able to
function you're gonna die and untied but
yeah like that's that's what's the thing
I was I was doing normal ass [ __ ] and I
was what out of you I was out here
trying to I would wake up go to baseball
practice do a workout and then all of a
sudden like I'm tweeting about how hard
I work like that's nothing so he did
like what every other key I did what
every little high school baseball player
basketball player ever did but I thought
I was just like I thought I was just on
I thought I was onto something guys I
thought I really had the secret formula
that everyone wished they had and I
thought Jay Cole and I were soul mates
you know their son yes what is it you're
looking at it one here comes the juice I
think is it called grindin yeah this is
my handsome y'all that sounds like the
$0.50 communally that for you every
morning when you wake up no I'm going to
be playing it for you cuz I'm up around
a grand an entire I'm doing more than
you and you need to know about anymore
I'm working so hard I'm doing more and
here's the evidence of my hard work a
nice nother little shot in SM mirror you
can see me in the paper because I'm
grindin that's really sweet though like
we when we did that show and tell her
whatever and we found that paper and
it's just like my name in there and it's
highlighted like I didn't have any
pictures of me in the paper like maybe
two in high school forever what have you
bought out a call and then like one and
not even like maybe a couple in college
but like it was really really really
special to get your name in the paper
oh yeah oh my god my mom has it's
collage of all the times my yeah see
that's like [ __ ] be so like that was
only two people in a couple times my
whole life it was a big deal yeah it was
definitely really cool I would one I
think one reason why we had a lot of
attention on us was my junior year toast
and Spencer and I ain't got traffic so I
caught him and that was really cool we
had a lot of scouts our games a lot of
prep but then my senior year we I don't
know what it was but the SM ear was
really really nice to us it was the
daily press in the mirror or really nice
to us they put us in the paper a lot my
mom kept all of those we put them all
together and maybe it was because you
guys are grinding so hard and they could
see it from so far away never stops
except if you don't even [ __ ] start
it because it's stupid stop stop trying
to grind stop let me let me move I can't
cry no you're touching me
hey babe why I'm go whining
you know what from now on when you call
me around the house and I'm busy I'm
going to just tell you that I'm busy
garden I'll only refer to you as grind
master daddy guys when anyone asks what
you're doing and you don't want to hang
out because you're sitting on the couch
now I can't grind you tell you're
grinding okay I'm gonna go grind in and
pop pop G he life is black pepper and
I'm the grinder
we need to end this [ __ ] five guys
already everybody out here you want to
see the evidence of my hard work
her name is peach she grinds - no she's
a grinder he'll join it was way out here
they use in tender but doing it over
here on his grinder you can't just say
grinding is yours grabbing a grinder
grinder mine I grinded before I know
kind of before grinder was a thing crime
did before grinder I thank you divided
what is that sense of quick ride round
round i ground but I ground my weight
man was so hard when I got grounded I
grinded oh my god
as you can see guys just [ __ ] us is
completely run its course we'll see you
guys next week or another podcast
until next week we will be grounded
we're gonna be working hard we're gonna
be killing the competition because we
got a game tomorrow
it's not the but the competition shut oh
yeah yeah writing yeah you're right it
is our city this is a public service
announcement and never use the word
grind or grinding because this is what
will happen to you return individualís
don't be like
you
[Music]
[Music]